back in my twenties I I really wanted to
write the the big Danish novel and I
tried to and every day I went instead to
the video store to see Tarantino movies
and then eventually I gave it up and
then I I attended the national school of
filmmaking in Denmark and and many years
after after the killing and so on I I
gained I think self-confidence enough to
try again and that's why and because I
wanted to challenge myself I mean I
didn't been writing TV series for many
years and I also did a few movies and
and it was just time now to try again
and it was every bit as lonely as I
feared it would be yes the writing
experience definitely you know when I'm
a mutually I'm a script writer and I'm
working together with the the actors and
directors and producers and so on so
it's something completely different to
do normal well tell us about the novel
it's for those who are fans of yours
from the killing they'll find it pretty
recognizable they will I think it's a
multiple layer story again and at its
core it has two detectives they don't
know each other in the beginning and
they get a task they have to solve a
murder in the suburbs and none of no one
actually who attends the crime scene
thinks it's important so it seems to be
an easy case and and then the forensics
they pick up chestnut Mane which is a
small icon children do in Denmark in
autumn and the forensics they discover a
fingerprint on this small chestnut man
and the fingerprint is from young girl
being the daughter of a famous
politician in the Parliament and that's
not a problem the problem is that the
the girl is presumed dead and has been
for a year
so how does a fingerprint show up on
this chestnut man and the two it's
detectives and they try to find out what
the connection is
let me told you about the killing we
surprised with its international
influence and even particularly were you
aware of just how it took Britain by
storm it was a slow burn people started
noticing and then it just spawned this
this huge love this interest in what we
we call scandi de noir hmm well it took
me completely by surprise because I
remember was a on a family vacation with
the wife and my kids and after two weeks
in Thailand I went to check my email and
then I returned to the swimming pool I
remember saying to my wife something is
going on now in the UK because I had so
many emails from from the UK
congratulating me and ensuring interest
and it was a surprise because at the
time it's a completely different world
now you can say but at the time and not
that many years ago actually it was
unthinkable that the UK and other
countries would even look at a Danish
show with subtitles well just tell me
about the the original ambition then
well you just thought it was obviously
thought it was it was well written and
it would appeal to the to the Danish
audience yes I thought I thought it
would I hoped it would go good in in
Scandinavia actually but I knew before
we programmed that it would be
impossible to do something to interest
the the British audience because of the
the subtitles and you know it I remember
my you my own Union I was I was you know
I was about to sign a contract with a
Danish Broadcasting Company and I had
some new negotiations of course and I
talked with my own union and I said what
about if we sell it to the to you know
outside countries and they said so and
don't think that way I mean you know
they don't read subtitles and I said
well just to be sure I'd like to get
just some kind of code
and luckily idea i succeeded with that
yes elastic energy I mentioned the other
things on my plate professionally it is
of course there the issue of brexit and
all the big votes taking place the big
decisions taking place in the United
Kingdom from your perspective from the
Danish perspective there you are you
puzzled by the whole process first of
all I'm just so sad that you're leaving
I really am because you know we we
joined with you and back then in 70s and
I think a lot of similarities between
the British and the Danish people when
it comes to regarding things in the in
the U and so I think if the Danes people
feel very much left alone when you leave
so I don't know it's it's it's of course
your decision
looking at Denmark and its relationship
with the European Union I mean there are
they you mentioned the similarities with
the with the UK nor in the Euro of
course they want to join the euro and
indeed when it comes to referenda have
voted against the do you voted against
treaties in the past third there is
there is a large degree of euro
skepticism within Denmark but not enough
to leave I think it's it's okay that to
have skepticism towards the EU why not I
mean it's a big institution of course I
still think that to my knowledge it's
better to to join the club and not being
part of it because I think it maybe
there's a bigger chance to to unite
European countries in that group but
what do I know I mean the future will
show us